You deserve to be doxed and you deserve worse. You're a cancerous
piece of >> He said, "Oh, there's no reason to." I I don't
know if I was the first one to suggest it or Jessica might have
even been the first one to suggest. I think that he's just lying
to cover his >> Yeah, I was I might have kind of this guy
to be honest with you. Unlucky.
If you are 17 and you are selling of yourself to people online,
you are selling child.
You are actually committing a crime.
I wouldn't say I would word things if you had a problem with
I would wear these things if I knew you were using as like a
public statement. Jesus. I wouldn't be throwing like smiley faces
into my in Omega or whatever into my if I knew you were publishing
these. Jesus. Remember, the only reason they even found the rose
person was because I posted the pics in chat to bait them into
looking.
Let's go. How reported does August
oh he has croo
pre-watching
he pre-watched
is lying
lawyers say it's over
red exclamation marks skull picture it's >> in my last
video I broke allegations on Destiny where in my DMs he admitted
to having on his computer with a 17-year-old named Rose. Hands
down the most shocking interaction I've had on YouTube since.
>> In fact, he did not admit it to having it on his computer.
But it is >> hit the fan with Destiny and Ethan going full
scorched earth, digging up old Reddit post, going after >> the
two most wild things you've experienced on YouTube both happened
in the past 2 weeks. I thought this guy's like 45 years old.
>> Family members. Destiny has made a video saying that
Rose's age still hasn't been confirmed. And Preach uploaded a
video echoing those same claims even though it's not true. Look,
I brought these allegations into this world and now that everyone's
responded, I want to set the >> You didn't bring anything
into this world. To be clear, the mysterious >> To be clear,
Destiny did provide the pictures that led to this woman being
doxed. Okay, Destiny brought these allegations into this world
himself.
this forum that for some reason every commentary YouTube guy
is Stop taking inches off his Okay, stop taking inches off his
he brought these allegations into the world, Willie. Do not take
his accomplishments from him. >> Who's scared to say by
name? So when Destiny's court case with Pixie is over, he could
respond to his most damning accusations in one place because
nobody, including me, is hoping Destiny has illegal his computer.
But the receipts against them are ugly and they need to be addressed.
Him deflecting to roses. >> The receipts against me. Oh
my god, this guy is so dirty. I pointed this out last time that
um Wait, the teeth
out the Oh,
I didn't know what this was referencing. Apparently, there's
like somebody was looking at a clip of like he's using a filter
or something. I don't even know. I saw Dickers looking at a clip
of this guy that seemed like there was some like weird happening
in this clip. Yeah, Toast Masters, don't worry. We'll go through
it like slowly. We'll just analyze what he says. Okay, you 100%
use the filter now. I think Dickers had something like analyzing
the flickering of the filter. >> Crows feet deleted. Is
this an AI picture? Was this even a real video? When this guy
uh tells me in DM, he's like, "Oh, don't worry. I'm not making
a video on this or anything." I feel like I would have been um
wait uh I would have phrased things a lot differently if I would
have known he was [__] publishing. This guy just
told me that child that he like would have reported me for child
if I talked about it. I wouldn't have told him that I had child
porn. If he would have just said, "Oh, buddy, just so you know,
child's like a red line for me." I would never have told him
that. No way. No way. >> Um, what am I thinking? Wait,
hold on. Off the record. >> Complaining about him having
nudes doesn't make it legal. >> I'm like the only person
in the history of the internet who people try to cancel based
on no person making any claims against me. >> So, he's
going to watch the video in two acts. But this is one thing that
I think is really funny. Just give me a second. Okay, even though
I have really tasty cornbread, I'm going to not eat any of it
while I review this video. Okay, going to show some self-control.
Not going to eat the cornbread while I do the video cuz that's
annoying. Okay, I've heard the I've heard the feedback. I've
heard the feedback. I won't do it while I'm while I'm watching
the video. Okay, listen. Listen to this. Okay, this is just really
funny. >> Doesn't make it legal. >> I'm like the
only person in the history of the internet who people try to
cancel based on no person making any claims against me. >> What
is this? So, so Desi is being accused of having child porn. And
his response is, "The child doesn't complain about me having
the child porn. Why are you mad?" The child hasn't lo hasn't
lodged a single complaint about me having the child porn. Why
are you upset? That's just think about it, right? There's no
victim coming forward. The child is okay with me having the child.
Uhhuh. Now, if you're a DG or if you're here from DGG and you're
watching this and you're like, "Uh,
she was 17 and a half. That's basically 18. Why would you call
her a child?"
I don't know, man. I don't know. If you want to make those arguments,
that's fine.
Seems kind of seems kind of odd. I just It feels a little weird.
Okay.
These are these are the people who he literally canceled Bob
7 using women that didn't come forward, by the way. Oh, that's
a great point. I forgot about that. That's uh Ellie Moon, right?
stream back since the allegations went live against him. Was
he to play the pedophile song? Also to again he says the allegations
these are not being made by a potential victim or any these are
just being made by other by non third parties which is
>> by the way just so we're aware okay if you are 17 and
you are selling of yourself to people online you are selling
child
you are actually committing a crime so there's every reason in
the world why the woman the girl involved in this wouldn't want
to come forward and wouldn't want to talk about it. In fact,
I would say probably most cases of child are not the child themselves
coming forward and saying this person's consuming child of me.
Maybe 95% of them are not like that. I don't know why. I don't
know where this who does he think he's convincing with this.
Yeah, the child is not normally coming forward in a case of child
or or trafficking uh transmitting child retaining child. It's
not normally the child who is in the that comes forward. >> Kind
of wild to me, but okay.
just a number.
>> Okay. Based >> totally kid. >> His Reddit
is talking about how he's liking post on Instagram of little
girls being his new girlfriend. Destiny. >> I like a ton
of crazy [__] on Instagram. Bro, is this the Are
we playing the game of Well, I really play this. I think we're
playing the game of everybody thinks you're like a weirdo who
pushes the boundaries of of the ages they can have sex interactions
with and you're leaning into it and you're rapidly losing any
plausible deniability you have,
right? Like I'm I'm sorry, but you have like credible allegations
that actually make people uncomfortable and your response is
to continue to lean into these allegations to make jokes about
it in a way that trivializes it. Of course, people are going
to react a certain way. But again, we're we're witnessing episode
9,762
of Destiny can't understand normal human emotions or reactions.
>> This game with Ethan. I don't think anybody wants to
play this game. I don't know what's in Willie Max Pass, but are
we going to like, bro, I have like so much crazy [__]
on Instagram.
Jesus. Always has the best optics. >> Also, I like how
he's like he's like Instagram. 1.6 million likes. A lot of people
like this on Instagram. Jesus. Little girls being his new girlfriend.
Destiny always has the best optics. I know everybody's a little
stressed. I know everyone's a little tense, but let's just take
a deep breath. >> Nobody's stressed. Nobody's
Um,
[__] Hold on. Oh, >> I don't know what's in
Willy Max's past. Oh. Oh, did I pull up the uh did I pull up
the tweet of Willie finding the real doxing community? Hold on
a second. Uh, they're like people from DG who are like, "Willie,
you deserve to be doxed." And actually, you deserve worse than
being doxed. Let me let me pull this one up. Let me let me find
this tweet from earlier today as file. I think I put it up in
the
food jobs tweeted some um let's see Kiwi farmer is trying to
dodge Alice from PWF defending. So apparently we're just going
to post this stuff to uh to Twitter and gain traction on it.
I don't know if people realize this like drawing attention to
this kind of thing usually doesn't end well for people but it
is what it is.
Lily Mack responds. Kiwi Farms people are speds and Alex does
not deserve that at all. These people are obsessed freaks and
dox my wife and I as well. I made a YouTube video. If Alex doesn't
like it and has criticisms for me, he has every right. This person
responds, "You deserve to be doxed and you deserve worse. You're
a cancerous piece of
Alex PWF is too busy [__] girls in the third world
to give a [__] about this lame shit." Yeah. Yeah,
I would say so. Check the response to that tweet. There's a response
to that tweet. I don't have that tweet up. I just have the the
pictures here. Hold on. How do I find the response to that tweet?
Uh Willie Willie Maxu.
Hold on. Hold on. Let me find.
Oh, there's a PWF thing. Um, I appreciate the love. I had no
idea my comment would get that that much attention. I may disagree
with you on Destiny, but your vids are still the Wow. What does
he disagree with on Destiny? I would love to know just on the
merits what he disagrees with. This guy's got a lot of clout
and I hang out with him. So, I'm going to say I disagree with
you. Actually, I can't see. If you want to link the response
to that, I can pull it up somewhere else, but I don't see a response
to it. So, I actually don't even see the actual tweet. So,
>> Wait. Okay. Sorry. I had a sense. >> Look at the
facts and use our sensibilities. And it's made that much >> Share
a link here or stream chat in the Discord. Either one. >> You're
with fume. That's the good stuff. Ever feel like you're stuck
in a habit you don't even think about? Maybe you're reaching
for something when you're hanging out with friends or in stressful
moments or just out of bored. This isn't a vape, eig, or nicotine
product. It's >> I take people who make public internet
content need to stop pretending like they're entitled to any
kind of privacy. Get a real job.
Uh that's maybe fine if that's like your principal position from
a base level, but that wasn't Destiny's principal position and
that's not what he that's not what he breaks from that breaks
away from that on. Right. It's not just people don't deserve
privacy in general. Um he just thinks if you talk about him in
a negative way, he gets to dox you. Yeah. He doesn't hold that
as like a principal position. He is just a emotion emotional
petulant child.
It's not like a thoughtout position. It's not like anything like
that is he's just a emotional petulant child. What is this?
Uh oh, I have this person blocked. That's why. Hold on. So, I
know it hurts, but let her go, buddy. It's not healthy holding
on to this anger. Oh.
Yeah. Okay. Interesting. A lot of delusional people out here.
>> Totally different without inhaling anything harmful.
Humans just flavored air gives you something to reach for without
all the harmful chemicals. And it comes in a wide variety of
flavors. But my >> You're not stressed at all. Are you
like a monk or something? I'm there are
there's the only thing there are two things that I'm stressed
about that I've been stressed about since the very beginning.
Um well not really well kind of. The first thing is um PR because
that's the most important thing and when it comes to my career,
right? Why would you block that account? They're awesome. Uh
I just do the Dan thing. Basically, if somebody like posts something
that's unrelated to my tweet, I just block in almost every case.
If I I can deal with people like doing uh criticisms. If you
actually have a criticism of my tweet or like some opinion, I'll
argue. I don't block those people. But if you're just like uh
you just like post something unrelated, I just block them. If
you're not engaging with like the subject of my tweet, I just
block basically all the time. Or are there people that think
I'm a or whatever? There. Hold on. Pull. >> Only thing
there are two things that I'm stressed about that I've been stressed
about since the very beginning. Um well, not really. Well, kind
of. The first thing is um PR because that's the most important
thing when it comes to my career. Right. Okay.
>> Yeah, I know you were most concerned about your career.
True think or whatever. Um, and the second thing is just what
is the next thing that opposing council is going to throw into
their next the 50 millionth motion that they throw in front of
the judge. Those I would advise Destiny to just stop like drawing
attention to the case. I think that's all he had to stop doing
or sorry, all you had to do. But he keeps trying to draw attention
to the case while they're like going for a protective order.
You keep trying to harass this woman. Of course, they're going
to keep filing evidence of your harassment when they're seeking
a protective order, like a gag order against you for the harassment.
Yeah, that's that's obvious. >> Those are the only two
things I'm concerned about for like the the problem is like for
the detailed >> Oh, sorry. I'm just thinking of things
in my head. The first thing I care about the most is PR. Okay.
So, you know, because I'm concerned about PR, I doxed the girl
I was That's the first thing I did for positive PR somehow. I
doxed the girl I was Turns out she was a minor. And now I've
proven that I've been retaining. I don't know. I don't know.
I don't know breakdown of reasoning for all of this stuff. And
I can explain all of this once my court case is concluded. I
cannot I just can't say publicly for reasons. And but if I even
if I say the reasons I think that opposing council is going to
throw things into into more motions. It's so unbelievably
it is. So the last motion that they filed was because he read
verbatim a sealed transcript on a public broadcast.
Right? So he's he's saying I can't talk about any of this because
they'll file more motions that they're just so evil with their
motions. The last motion they filed is because he publicly read
a sealed transcript
verbatim on a live stream. It it wasn't persecution. It wasn't
them treating him unfairly. It's not them being unhinged or crazy.
It's them saying, "Oh, we had this transcript sealed because
we're trying to wait for a ruling on whether or not it can be
released because there's details in it we don't want released
as a part of, you know, pertaining to some of the other protective
orders or some of the other things we have sealed." Uh, witness
identities. Um, just a general like Jane Doe element here where
we she doesn't want her details revealed, right? Yeah, you could
chase. You can go look it up. It's it's in the motion court listener.
Go find it. Very easy to look up yourself. So he read that transcript
off
and they filed a motion saying he read the transcript off verbatim.
Yeah, that's totally understandable. Did you cover that? I did.
It was
>> So anyway, he's like playing this up as it's something
that's it's like uh persecuting him. He is like being treated
unfairly. He's being treated completely fairly. he did something
that was totally against the rules and against the will of the
the judge who was ruling on the case that I'm being sued for
$15 million and I'm expected to divulge
information about people keep saying like oh well why is he saying
anything about this has nothing to do with court case the these
are the DMs and my court case is concerning this is everything
to do with my court what are you talking about if not for this
person there is no court case so this uh wait hold on so like
is he actually said because I but that Abby referenced other
videos from their DMs that aren't a part of his court case. He
said they shouldn't be introduced into evidence. They have no
relevance to the court case. Are these child videos that are
sent to him by Rose, are they suddenly a part of the court case?
Are they important evidence for the court case? Because I thought
he was saying any video that didn't include him and Pixie was
irrelevant. Any victim that was not him or that was not Pixie
was irrelevant, even if they were brought up in the same DMs.
So, I don't understand what he's saying here. He's he's completely
swapped his standard from early on in the case where, oh, Abby,
you know, wants to reference other videos. Those shouldn't be
allowed in any filings, guys, cuz they're irrelevant to the case.
But my the child videos in the original DMs, those are totally
relevant to the case. Those are really important to the case,
guys. They're so important to the case right now.
People like him were like, "Oh, I don't know why." Like, you're
so stupid, bro. Holy [__] >> Favorite part
about Fimus. It's the greatest adult fidget toy ever created.
Twist it, pull it, pop it on its magnetic stick. >> They
already make adult fidget toys. They're called your your own.
>> Whenever I get in a slump at work, I distract myself
by pulling out my phone or getting up and grabbing another cup
of coffee that I definitely don't need. Now, I just grab my fume,
fidget with it a bit, get a little stimulant of flavor, and I'm
right back to work. So, come join the over 500,000 people that
use fume. And right now, if you order the journey pack today
using code Willy Mac, you'll get a free fume topper. So, if you've
been thinking about changing your bad habits, this is the perfect
first step. So, go to tryfume.com/ymack
or scan the QR code to grab yours today. Thank you fume for sponsoring
this video. Willy Mack decides to run and make a video like 2
hours after DMing me. No, I understand. I get it. Okay, we have
to do the Destiny bad. >> Oh, I don't even hear all of
the lies anymore. Lutgious Gamer, did you bring Did you bring
up the 15 million again? By 15 million. Uh, again, I'll just
keep pointing out and he can anytime he wants to say that this
is a lie.
Pixie's lawyers told him, "We will accept a lower offer from
you. This is not our final offer. We're not like standing on
this. Like, give us a good offer back and we will like play ball.
We will we will absolutely settle this." Okay, that was communicated
to him to his council and he's welcome to dispute that if he
likes because we're it's too much to eat other people. >> I
love how he doesn't honestly engage. He just immediately tries
to my character. It's very >> doesn't honestly engage.
I'm starting the video off. Oh my god. Really? I will just pay
him. >> Oh, hold on. We got a donation. >> Reban
Ruben donated $3 and is funnier because Destiny is fuming. >> Uh,
thank you, Reuben. Ruben, appreciate the three. I like how Willy's
video against me isn't about me at all. Oh, I like how it's just
a giant cigarette ad or vape ad or whatever the [__]
this is ad. The whole thing is just an ad, by the way, because
that's what the start of the video was. >> Very clear why
I went to the police. It's because he sent me a screenshot of
what he described as videos of >> Why is he saying this?
It's clear why I went to the police. I literally explicitly say,
"I don't care if you want to report me." Whatever. That's fine.
That's not my issue. The issue is making a public video about
something you told me you weren't even making a video on and
then throwing screenshots in there. Like, I have these as like
PR public ready statements. Jesus, these I don't He's spuring
out. Yes, he is acting like a child, right?
I don't even want to do the thing. He's just spurring the out,
right, brother? Just calm down and explain what he's getting
wrong here cuz we've walked through these very slowly. There
is no reason for you to claim that these would be something other
than CSAM. Everything you say about this makes no sense. Just
talk through it slowly like an adult, like somebody with any
self-control.
just calmly talk through what you think happened or you know
prove to all of us that you're completely incapable of that >> a
17-year-old having with other guys his words I didn't want to
misunderstand him so I asked very clearly is the video he just
described what he was sending me he responded depends why you're
asking which could very obviously >> try to serious question
how long does an FBI investigation into CP possession take before
arrest people have been making these let me just put it this
way people making these claims for over a year okay lots of claims
have been made by a lot of people I'll just put it that way okay
>> be a joke but it also implies under the right circumstance
he could have sent this to me and then he said yes confirming
that he still has >> why does he and then also what is
this >> be a joke but it also implies under the right circumstance
he could have sent this to me and then >> like is the implication
that if you want I've got a whole bunch of like that we could
both goon over what where does this what >> said yes so
what's the meme here of uh depends on why you're asking
right uh Destiny's already gone by this I think does Willie not
open the video in the best way I think Willie does Willie open
it he's got this first okay so
Destiny sends Just in case you weren't here earlier, guys, Destiny
sends a screen cap and says, "Oh, actually, we have to go to
the Willie thing again. We have to actually go to his uh media
posts because you need this." Okay, this is the actual screenshot.
Desty sends this log from Rose.
It's fine. It was fun. Other than that, I'll see if I can salvage
any of the recordings my boyfriend made for you. Smiley face,
right? Although, this is on April 19th, so this is way before
that, right? I didn't notice until this until way later, but
the videos she'd record with other guys. The file names are like
screen recording this. So, she's doing something with other guys,
right? What was she doing with other guys? Why did Destiny accuse
Solo of trafficking?
Seems like pretty obviously he's talked about her having with
other guys. I know he's referenced that, right? So, these are
videos of other guys that have titles like this, which is the
exact title of the video Destiny sends a screen cap of.
Okay, the exact title of that video. Destiny goes on to say her
boyfriend was recording these on Skype calls. That's just absolutely
insane to to think about him doing all of this if she was 17.
What would be insane to do if she was 17? That is not child porn
here. Can anybody explain that to me? I'm just calmly thinking
through it. If we have an excuse, if she was folding laundry,
she was ironing shirts. I don't think that's insane to do if
she was 17, right? I don't think that's insane to do. So, there's
something she was doing with other guys that her boyfriend was
recording. And the only other thing we'd ever heard about this
with other guys was her having sex with other guys, and it would
be insane to do because she was 17, right? So, he's about to
allege that these aren't actually child. I was never saying I
had child. I don't think this video isn't child, but there's
just no possible way to allege that given what we know about
these logs and about his relationship with Rose and Rose's boyfriend.
Anyway, we continue. >> Fine. That's not my issue. The
issue is make sure we be on this joke, >> but it also implies
under the right circumstance he could have sent this to >> like
is the implication that if you want I've got a whole bunch of
like that we could both goon over. What? Where does this what
>> said yes confirming that he still has when I said that
it's crazy that he was telling me that he has C on his computer.
He doesn't deny it. Instead, he gives reasons for why he's allowed
to keep it. On stream, he said he was sharing this stuff with
other people to try and find her. >> Oh, yeah. Because
I have screenshots of Yeah. Yes. The We were doing detailed
vaginal analysis to try to figure out. We tried to Okay. So,
I I'm assuming he's aware that there's an allegation that he
was sending like CSAM into this group, right? Sweep a meme. Sweep
a meme, dude. Uh
there's another Nope. We're going to wait. Sweeping meme. Sweep
a meme. So, he's just going to totally pass by the fact, right,
the fact that he was sharing these these pictures with a group
chat >> computer. He doesn't deny it. Instead, he gives
reasons for why he's allowed to keep it on stream. He said he
was sharing this stuff with other people to try and find her.
>> Oh, yeah. Because I have screenshots of Yeah. Yes. The
We were doing detailed vaginal analysis to try to figure out.
We tried to do identification for some of these videos. >> Okay.
He says he's analyzing these videos as in multiple videos, but
these videos are ceasing. >> Try to find her through her
boyfriend as There is like is he is he under the impression that
this is off the record as he's streaming it live or why is he
still saying completely
things even through irony? I don't think he's actually talking
about that. Wait, are you talking about him saying we're doing
detailed vaginal analysis? >> Got to figure out we tried
to do identification for some of these videos. >> Okay.
He says he's analyzing these videos as in multiple videos, but
these videos are ceasing. >> Try to find >> Yeah,
it's it's a joke, right? It's a joke. Haha. You're a very good
one, Goon. You got me. Got me, buddy. All right. So, somehow
he's trying to tell us that he sent these these videos that are
clearly not every single contextual indicator in the entirety
of these logs says that they're right. Says that it's he's sending
of somebody who is 17 when it's sent. I I don't know how he could
fool anybody here. He kind of just pauses and does
I would have said totally different things. I would have joked
at all. I wouldn't have joked at all. Right. And it's it's just
we can just very slowly walk through exactly what he's done,
what he said, and it's obvious. I don't know why nobody in his
community is capable of boyfriend.
>> There is so much is not true about that statement. This
is for real. Like in 6 months, okay, screenshots of >> guys,
we'll solve it all in six. In six months, I'll tell you about
it. Okay? Once they throw out the case, once they throw out the
case, I'll have posted the January 6 video. In 3 months, we'll
have it all. We'll have it all out there, okay? It'll all be
out there. It'll all be You guys will understand everything just
in 6 months, okay? I promise. I
It's So, what I don't understand is he's already published this.
This is all public. If this wasn't harming his case, if telling
Willie about this wasn't harming his case, why didn't he react
to this by going, "Hey, Willie, I'm going to send you this full
video. Could you confirm for everybody that the video with this
thumbnail that includes the frame I just sent you is not child?"
He could do that to Willie in confidence. What would the video
be that is scary for him to send to Willie?
That would further endanger his case,
right? I I don't understand what that would be unless it's child.
It could only clear up the public misunderstanding. And if it
would clear up Willy's misunderstanding, Willie would go, "Oh,
this wasn't child. I totally misunderstood.
I totally misunderstood this." Okay, but he's not doing it. He
he could easily do that. He's choosing not to do it. when she
would record stuff, she literally has um a lot of done sight
calls with her boyfriend, which I didn't really figure out at
the >> How much more clear could it be that this guy has
C on his computer, but fast forward a little >> just let
me just throw this into the ether. Okay, now Willie might be
a freak. Okay, and I'm just I'm not aware of it, but there are
other things, believe it or not, that you can record that have
nothing to do with like stuff. That's possible.
Yeah, there totally are. There's actually there are totally things
you could record, but the prerequisites for those things is she
was recording things with other guys. You've talked about how
Rose was other guys on camera and that her boyfriend was recording
it. Uh it is also insane for him to be recording these things
when she's under 17. You said yourself that the videos with other
guys have titles like the video screen cap you gave,
right? I didn't notice this until way later, but the videos she'd
record with other guys, the file names are like screen recording
this. Oh, that's the that's the exact thing that was there. Oh,
that's the exact thing that was there. Oh, uh the her boyfriend
was recording these on Skype calls. And so the other thing, okay,
it's videos with other guys that have titles like this. All right.
And then it's just absolutely insane to think about him doing
all of this if she was 17.
What would what would she be recording with other guys somewhere
when she was 17? That would be a problem. It's like so easy to
just see that from these logs he's like clearly lying now. He's
clearly making things up. And yes, it was only an innocent video.
Why crop the video in the screenshot? Why not send the full video
to Willy Mack to clear it up, right? Shouldn't that be pretty
easy? You just send the whole video to Willy Mack. Now you clear
it up. He he takes down his video. He says, "Oh, I I misunderstood
completely. This video is totally something else, guys."
No, I'm just throw that in the ether. Not that that has any possible
anything to do with anything. I'm just saying that that is possible.
Now, maybe not for Willie. Maybe not for Playboy Willie over
here. Okay. But >> then he's tweeting. >> I mean,
no. Based on the exact things you said, it's not possible at
all. Yeah. So, this is only you can only think this if if your
only guiding star for truth in the world is Destiny's voice and
the things Destiny says. You cannot believe this if you look
at all the evidence. You look at like the messages as they were
sent. You can't believe that he is being honest in any way, right?
He'd already sent a bunch of information to Willie, so he's clearly
not worried about if Willie was going to hide this stuff, if
Willie was going to keep this to himself, right? He's not worried
about Willie uh, you know, putting this out into the in the public
in any way, right? As long as it's not child, if that's Willy's
only line. So, you're saying it's not child, why not clear this
up with Willie? He recants. He takes back his video. He clears
your name. Shouldn't that be pretty easy? I have no on my computer.
He's saying he would word things differently if you knew I would
have a problem with it. >> I don't know why you talked
to Willneck at all. No,
I wouldn't say I would word things differently if you had a problem
with it. I would word things different if I knew you were using
as like a public statement. Jesus. I wouldn't be throwing like
smiley faces into my in Omega or whatever into my Yeah. If I
knew you were publishing these. Jesus. The smileys and omegaols
are not the problem with the statements, right? Although they
are offputting, sure, they are like weird, but they're not the
problems with the statements. If you aren't going to change the
statements, the statements are standing on their own. Then you're
in even even worse place. Like you're in a totally worse place.
Uh this without the smileys is just as damning.
I don't know why he thinks the smileys are the damning part of
this. It's uh odd. This is um I don't remember. I think he messaged
me on something, but I mean I've been in communication with him.
I just didn't expect them to run and make a YouTube video in
2 seconds based off of DMs with us. Obviously the approach that
converation a lot more care in terms of finding things obviously
>> instead of yes to keep >> Oh, I didn't think about
this. You're right. Chinese agent. He definitely saw the part
of the stream where we're making fun of him of doing, "Yeah,
I do have child." Lol W. Yeah, I do have Child L W. Like the
Pepe laugh he put when threatening to leak out his nudes. I don't
know if he did a Pepe laugh after that, but sure. I'm sure that
would be the same thing. >> Would you have said no? Cuz
that would obviously change a lot. Like your entire statement.
He's literally rewriting history in front of our very eyes because
saying yes would be a crime. >> I don't have every reason
to believe this person was 19 anyway. So >> no, he doesn't
have every reason to believe that. Especially since Rose's boyfriend
Solo told him in November of 2024 that she was 17. That's >> I
don't know why he keeps relying on this guy's DMs when he messaged
me the as he Oh, right, right, right. I forgot he actually invokes
me here. He's telling me this. You understand? This guy has every
incentive to lie about her age as well, right? He's
Yeah, he does have an incentive to lie about her age, but he
told you that and you were totally freaking out that it was that
she wasn't a like an adult. You didn't check. You weren't certain
at all. Right. I get the feeling you checked those Twitter DMs
and realized that you didn't really check at all. Right. He's
going to use me. I I've said this a hundred times on stream.
I totally thought that solo guy was lying.
Um I guess this is the one instance that Destiny finds me trustworthy
is going to be when I say I think Solo's lying. Everywhere else
I'm not trustworthy, but just on on Rose's age and Solo, whether
or not Solo should be trusted on whether or not she's a minor,
that's where I'm like totally trustworthy. 100% trustworthy.
Leaking revenge of me. He's engaging in extortion and blackmail
to try to come onto my stream and he's posting everything else
to other Discord servers and Kiwi Farms. I don't know why people
keep citing this guy as like the He hadn't posted what he hadn't
posted the uh the leaks at this point, right? I'm pretty sure
when you're told she's a minor, your revenge wasn't posted,
right? So, he he tries to muddy timelines. Destiny will do this
all the time. He does this like a hundred different times in
this segment. He just tries to muddy timelines because he knows
that if he can muddy the timelines, he can manipulate facts.
The fact is
your videos weren't leaked when he told you she was a minor.
Stop bringing that into into this as if that's like a part of
your calculus, right? I believe it's November 24th. Unless maybe
it's Am I crazy? I'm pretty confident it's November 24th. Dicker
said earlier on his stream, Solo only wanted $50 in stream time.
You can't give Solo $50 in stream time. You can't give him money.
You can't give him anything. You can't negotiate with people
like this, right? Yes, the first leak was only the Lauren Southern
DMs and some of the context around the Lauren Southern DMs. I
think some of the embarrassing sexs, but none of the videos.
And the guy was trying to blackmail Destiny cuz he Destiny knew
that he had videos of him like sucking dick and [__]
So, he was trying to blackmail Destiny, but he hadn't leaked
that stuff. And while he maybe has incentive to to say Rose is
a minor to prevent people from looking into her. Uh if I had
a bunch of material of the person he was saying was a minor,
I
I'd probably look into that. Okay. A little bit. I think I'd
look into that. I'd be a little concerned about that personally.
Ultra reputable source of things that are true and real. Again,
and I will stress this and I have all the logs for this. Dysle
didn't believe it either. Drisle did not think that this guy
was being truthful either. I think he somehow despite being my
biggest fan. He doesn't know that I talked about this like a
hundred different times on stream. Yeah, I didn't think she was
uh I thought he did that in reaction to me showing him that he'd
leaked the like her Twitter account, but guess what? That wasn't
true.
Couldn't he have gone to the police at that point, November 24?
Uh, yes, he could have. He could have gone to the police. He
could have sought the advice of legal counsel. He could have
done basically anything, right? And and then I would say once
stuff started to leak and her age was proven, then he absolutely
has a burden to go to the police, right? But it didn't seem like
he was very concerned with going to the police. It seemed like
he was more concerned with, you know, his civil case for some
reason. Cuz I I don't believe he'd gone to the police as of like
Willie Max submitting this, as far as I know. He said, "Oh, there's
no reason to." I I don't know if I was the first one to suggest
it or Jessica might have even been the first one to suggest.
I think that he's just lying to cover his
>> Yeah, I was.
I I might have kind of this guy to be honest with you. Unlucky.
Too bad he spent the past like uh what do you call it? Past like
eight months totally trying to run my name through the mud. He
could go, "Oh, I trusted this guy. Oh, you trusted the guy you
called who lies about everything. Who's lied about all of your
who?" Yeah. It's not like he can go with no I totally trust this
guy. Right. He's kind of run my name through the mud and his
like there's a ton of public exper or a ton of public
statements showing that he doesn't trust my word for oh boy.
But >> to be fair to Destiny, it's not like >> is
he would say he trusted you at the time? Why would he trust me
after Rose's age came out? Why would he trust me anywhere after
like any of this stuff had gone through? Why would he trust me
once he realized like I I'm positive that he knew that she was
younger, right? Has Desi ever filed a police report? I don't
know if bombs. I have no idea. I'm looking for a tweet right
now. Solo is a good guy here. The whole reason why all this drama
start not like a good guy. >> That's one way to phrase
it, Willie. >> With Destiny is because Solo logged into
Rose's Discord account and shared all of the messages between
her and Destiny. This is how we found out Destiny was non-conensually
sharing his nudes of previous partners to >> shared the
messages. Also, this is uh under contention right now. >> Random
eirl, but we only know about it because Solo shared all of this
revenge online. Him doing this has led to a ton of people around
Destiny getting >> Okay, guys, real quick. I do need one
tweet. It's the tweet where Destiny says something like he he
tweets something out publicly like how do you think Huey Farms
was able to find her and he's referencing him leaking the public
stuff on Rose. Could I get that tweet? Does anyone have that
tweet? Someone can find me that tweet. I'd really appreciate
it. >> All of this comes from Solo in his
led to what the [__] what was that summary of events?
What >> main motivation for doing it is because he was
bored. This guy sucks. But this guy doing these awful things
has opened Destiny up to valid criticism. I've already made two
videos talking about the Pixie situation. Go check that If Destiny
is upset that this is being brought up again, he should have
never shared those videos with some random girl over the internet
that he didn't even care. >> If I didn't want Willie publishing
my DMs, I shouldn't have been talking to me in 2022.
My bad. True. You got me on there. That was a good That was a
very good >> Know the age of responsibility lands on hit.
He's tweeting the 60 GB screenshot was related to a claim the
Rose person made. Someone whose name and birthday have yet to
be reliably confirmed. >> This is not the 60 GB ink folder
or >> And he shows why he knows there's a 60 GB drive of
Rose's underage videos. >> If you have the size, you should
have it on your PC. It's just a screenshot that she sent me the
folder. I mean, I could post a screenshot of what she told me.
If someone ever hacks mine and my boyfriend's cloud storage,
they will find a treasure trove. I swear I have 310 folders of
photo sets. Total size 61.15 GB. >> But the context of
her sending Destiny this is that she would send him those videos
that her boyfriend recorded. She
>> No, it's not one that I I know that he doesn't have
that context because that never even happened. Like, how does
he have more knowledge of my conversation with this person than
I have? This didn't even happen. No. What are you talking about?
Told him I'll see you. Does this matter? Is this just Is this
just him like biting down on on a tiny possible factual inaccuracy
that he could like totally like corkcrew down on? He like bites
down on like an alligator. He does like the death roll with it.
Is that what he's trying to do here? Like there's some tiny piece
that's that might be inaccurate there. Maybe like in this one
case she wasn't offering like those recordings, but like here
she's offering recordings, right? Here she's definitely offering
recordings. So they might not be the same recordings. The vid
the video set might not go to this precisely, right? see if I
can salvage any of these recordings my boyfriend made for you.
SD then even then sent me a screenshot of a video he has open
and describes it as an underage video Rose sent. Her boyfriend
was recording these on Skype calls. That's absolutely insane
to think about him doing all of this. If she I'll just I'll just
point out that um
when Destiny says because of the lawsuit, I can't reveal anything
else to you. You always know he's lying because of one special
thing Willie Mack did. Will he really focus in on that 60 gigabytes
of child, right? What did Destiny do the second that 60 GB of
child point got brought up? He immediately went to his logs,
he immediately pulled the screenshot so that he could immediately
show that he was innocent of that charge. Right? If Destiny has
uh excerating
evidence for himself, he will immediately pull that evidence
and show it publicly. And he's done this repeatedly. He's not
done that for almost any of this the rest of the Willie video.
But for that 60 gigabytes thing, he instantly dove into those
rose logs. He didn't give a about the lawsuit. He went, "Oh,
look, Willy Mack's lying. Willie's lying." So the idea that he
can't exonerate himself now because of the court case is insane.
If when he's able to exonerate himself, he does so instantly.
>> He was 17. He's describing and acknowledging that he
has CP. I
>> the first of all that's not even the message is literally
that I seriously don't think that this is that number one. Number
two again you don't know exactly. So that's him saying when he
says uh it's absolutely insane to think about him doing all this
if she was 17. She was proven to be 17 at this point. Okay. Proven
to be 17,
right? She's proven. And he says, "Oh, my message here was just
that like I really don't think this is true. It doesn't matter
if you don't think 2+ 2 is four. 2 plus two is four. Reality
matters. You can't just say you were like in a temporary state
of mania. You're temporarily hallucinating that she wasn't 18.
I don't think that's a your honor. I was in a state of disbelief.
I was in a fugue state where I couldn't accept the fact that
she was under 18. So, I don't believe I should be held responsible
for not deleting or coming forward with any of that content.
I was in a fugue state. I don't think that's a reasonable point.
I don't I don't think that's a reasonable reasonable point at
all. Anyway, what this video is because he didn't because he
I think sometimes I think some people think that I'm just like
setting him.
Okay. I don't know if he if he implied that in the first video
if some people are just running with that explanation, whatever.
Um but again, for reasons that will be very clear and whenever
the my court case is over, I can talk about this a little bit
>> Ask him and he answers yes. Giving reasons why he can
keep it on his >> apparently with this one thing. With
this one thing, he has to wait until the court case is over.
We couldn't we couldn't possibly cover it now, guys. No way.
No way.
>> Computer. When he pulls it up on screen, he acknowledges
that this is that Solo recorded her >> cuz I have screenshots
of when she would record stuff. She literally has um a lot of these
were done via Skype calls with her boyfriend, which I really
figure at the time, but we tried to find out who the boyfriend
was based on initials and stuff from here, too. But this is not
a 60 GB
or whatever. >> No, it's just one gigabyte of He's lying
when he's saying this is an unsharable reading. These are very
direct questions and he's giving very direct answers. Yet, his
viewers copen me. But he didn't do that. He doesn't stop to read
the quotes, right? He just lets the logs flow by. Doesn't stop
to read them. How are you going to disprove what he's saying
if you don't read them and you don't respond? Destiny, are you
really going to be this dishonest? Somebody directly shows him
that he did say yes to having CP and then it becomes when he
was just making general statements. It's not general at all.
It's actually very specific statements. Destiny viewers, these
DMs are your emperor has no clothes moment and you're choosing
to be blind. Hold them to a higher standard. As far as Rose's
age goes, it's been confirmed since August 20th. This is due
to Destiny posting information. >> Just no response >> about
her college. Kaki Farms failed to touch the doxer. Well, they
found her and she's wearing Destiny's merch. Same girl from the
Twitter account. They found her name listed on college. >> If
you genuinely think this is why I don't believe any of these
people are real people. If you So we're going to get the This
is going to be the performative outrage for the people that he
clearly has no concern for who he will do the exact things to
those people. Okay? He'll do the exact things he's virtue signaling
over that he's concern trolling about to those people and then
he will pretend that he's actually in the right here. Okay? Genuinely
believe that this is an underage victim of like online crazy
whatever. Why the [__] would you publish? Why the
[__] would you dox this person in your YouTube video?
In your YouTube video. Why would you dox this person in your
YouTube video? Why would you dox this person in your YouTube
He's doing it again. He's doing it again. He's doing it again.
Because as we know, uh, Destiny is the person who doxed her.
Literally the person who doxed her, right? And
strangely, like to me at least, strangely,
he took direct direct responsibility for it. So, we've got this
here. Okay.
What is this? Something about uh Hassan
Eli B hops in and says, "I'm so curious. Do you still think you
can't sweep and meme your way out through this like you did with
the non-conentual,
or if not, what changed your mind?" Destiny says, "If she was
legit a minor, she was. We knew this at the time. You can you
tell me why no one seems to care that Solo was legitimately trafficking
her? Wait, that means like getting her to record videos that
with other guys? Are those the videos with other guys and using
her to honeypot people?
Those are federal felonies, by the way. I wonder if those federal
felonies might be why we don't have her coming forward to accuse
you of something. Actually, I've been thinking this over. I would
like to see the police look into this if for no other reason
than he could be exploiting the other uh other girls. Only one
of us can make that happen. Want redemption? Stephen, go to the
police tomorrow and give them everything you have.
And he responds, I have nothing to give them. Lie. Remember,
the only reason they even found the rose person was because I
posted the pics in chat to bait them into looking. So, these
are the pictures, guys. These pictures that Will is showing in
his video that Destiny so the out about are the exact pictures.
Actually, slightly more censored. the exact pictures that Destiny
himself posted in his chat that Willie just showed a screenshot
of right >> your emperor has no clothes moment and you
were choosing to be blind hold them to a higher standard as far
as Ros's age goes it has been confirmed since August 20th this
is due to Destiny posting information about her college >> these
exact so her her college the pictures of her these are things
that he posted that were sent to him obviously with her full
face in them wearing his merch right and he says explicitly that
he's looking to bait Kiwi Farms with these videos. >> Makiwi
Farms failed at Tonsox. Well, they found her and she's wearing
Destiny's merch. Same girl from the Twitter account. They found
her name listed on college. >> If you genuinely think,
this is why I don't believe any of these people are real people.
If you genuinely believe that this is an underage victim of like
online crazy, whatever, why the would you publish why the would
you dox this person your YouTube video? This person who's not
even The only reason they even found the Rose person was because
I posted the pics in chat to bait them into looking. Um, this
is like the performative concern trolling that is totally lizardlike.
Like he's actually inhuman,
right? To make these arguments. Like it's I don't want to get
too performative about it. It's very disgusting to me, right?
Like he doesn't feel empathy. He's learned to feain empathy or
feain concern, but he doesn't feel it. It's not there. He is
like a lizard,
right? He will do whatever he can. He'll figure out how he can
get people on his side by by feigning outrage by feigning some
like some uh moral outrage over things, right? It doesn't it
doesn't exist. It's not there, right? Uh this is another part
Freie like it's um he is he's obviously writing the script for
people, right? He's watched like what the rest of the people
have said. He's clearly writing the script as well for people.
This is how you should attack Willy. This is how you should go
after Willie. Is like this. Don't worry about me doing the exact
thing. Just go after Willie with this. Okay. even publicly making
a claim or saying anything publicly by the way at all. Right?
The child in my child in the child I hold isn't even complaining.
Why are you mad?
That's what he's saying here. Okay. By the way, as we know, Rose
isn't doing that obviously because she was engaging in selling
child porn. That's still a problem even if you're 17. You can
still get in big trouble for that. That's that's like it's just
unfathomable to me. I I can't what the thought process is. That's
not true. It's unfathomable what the thought process is if this
is what you're saying is your thought process. Right? The goal
the thought process here is if you don't show how obvious it
is that Destiny is disingenuous and lying to his audience that
he will slither away from these allegations that he'll say we're
we don't know that this is true. We don't know that this is proven.
Right? And you want him to look as ridiculous as he possibly
can when he tries to slither away from these allegations that
she was 17 and it's proven. He helped prove it and now he's trying
to slither away from the fact that G7. He's trying to slither
away from the fact that he's responsible for all of this. Right?
And he's performing outrage for the exact things he did and that
he originated. He put this information out first. It was information
uniquely available to him that he published to try to bait Kiwi
Farms, the evil Kiwi Farms, into doxing this girl. Self admitted.
>> Well, if you're to do hit piece on me, then I hit piece
away. Holy. >> They found the same girl living in the same
town because of this local >> Jesus Christ. >> And
her birthday is October of 2004. This is confirmed. >> So
just to be clear, >> girl living in the same town because
of this local >> Jesus Christ.
>> And her birthday. >> So Destiny argues that Oh,
there's only one database. This is a second database that they
found her information in where it says she's born in October
of 2004.
A second database, right?
Second publicly available database
that says how old she is that proves that she was a minor. birthday
is October of 2004. This is confirmed again with a traffic violation
and she's the only person with that name in that town and she
fits that exact description. Meaning that when Destiny was sending
and receiving material from her, she was underage. The video
that Destiny showed me he still had is titled with the date of
August 14th, 2022, meaning she was 17 in that video. That is
a legal upon telling them that she's a minor, no reason to think
the docs is wrong. Destiny doesn't go, "Oh, I better turn this
over to authorities." He replies with why he thinks he should
still keep it. He doesn't even know for a fact. I don't think
I'm allowed to delete it. I don't know if it counts as high.
>> Why? When Willie asks, "You can't have that. Why wouldn't
you delete this if you thought she might be 17?" Why does he
respond? I don't think I'm allowed to delete it. He doesn't respond.
No, no, no. She was 18. He doesn't respond. No, no, no. Like,
it's not. He responds. Well, I don't know if I'm allowed to delete
it. I'm trying Hold on. I have to I'm trying to think of what
I can say. Oh my god. I can't wait until Dude, this is going
to be the final manifesto. I said the last two manifesto be the
final manifesto. Um, okay. Let me give a totally unrelated example.
Okay.
Okay. A totally unrelated example, guys. Final manifesto because
they won't let him publish to YT/ Shutter from jail or because
after it nothing.
It's also interesting dual thing he's doing where he's insisting
he must have thought she was 18, but also the videos aren't um
Yeah, sure. That's also strange that he's insisting it's not
proven out. >> Let's say that >> here. I have to
pull this back just a little bit. Did he did he respond to any
of this? And her birthday
is confirmed again with a traffic violation and she's the only
person with that name in that town and she fits that exact description.
Meaning that when Destiny was sending and receiving material
from her, she was underage. The video that Destiny showed me
he still had is titled with the date of August 14th, 2022, meaning
she was 17 in that video. That is illegal. Upon telling them
that she's a minor, no reason to think the docs is wrong. Destiny
doesn't go, "Oh, I better turn this over to authorities." Replies
with why he thinks he should still keep. >> She doesn't
want any part of this because she committed a crime. >> He
doesn't even know for Sorry, I'm looking at the chat. He doesn't
respond to it at all. He just lets it go by,
He just lets it go by. Never seen him so panicked. I mean, you
think he'd really do that if he gets caught? No. He'd think he
could like talk his way out of it until the jail house door slams
behind him. >> If If something comes of this, who knows?
I don't know if it counts as >> I'm trying Hold on. I I'm
trying to think of what I could say. Oh my god. I can't wait
until Dude, this is going to be the final manifesto. I said the
last two manifesto be the final manifesto. Um >> I thought
he was done with drama, guys. Isn't he done with drama, guys?
I think he's I thought I'd heard that this guy was done with
drama that it was over. We're all done with the drama now. Is
he not Are we going back to the drama? And then every time where
it's like it's every time it's checkmate, you're holding child.
He's like, "No, you don't understand. I have a final trap card.
Uh it's this lawsuit that's unrelated to the child. I can't tell.
I can't tell you anything else." Okay? Pay no attention to the
fact that that 60 GB screenshot, I pulled that out instantly
to disprove Willie on the 60 GB claim. Pay no attention to that
fact. Okay, I can't show anything else. >> Okay, let me
give a totally unrelated example.
Okay,
let's say that. >> Hold on. It's this. It's this. >> Just
when I thought I was out, they pulled me back in. >> Yeah,
seems to be that. >> Let's say that I'm building a computer.
>> Let's say that I have a whole bunch of um graphics cards.
Okay. >> Wow. He's got a bunch of graphics cards. Let's
say that when I go to build my
>> Okay. Got a bunch of graphics cards. When you go to
build when I go to build my computer, as in maybe the graphics
cards aren't placed yet. >> Let's say that I'm trying to
think of I can't do this with an analogy. >> Is this like
all DG needs now? They don't even need the like they don't need
a manifesto. They don't need reasoning. They just need he he
can just go like he could smirk and go, "Huh? Let me open up
paint. Let me do an analogy. Wait, you know what? I I can't do
this with an analogy, actually." And they're like, "He was confident.
He was confident enough to do the analogy, guys. He could have
he could have totally owned them if he'd wanted to. He could
have totally owned them. Okay,
this statement is being interpreted as though I don't know or
I have no idea how I'm supposed to treat stuff that I have archived
for a court case. When another reading of the statement is you
don't know what will be relevant related to a court case, if
that makes sense. You could make reasonable inferences. Uh, if
you have any child, if you've received any videos from Rose,
which the idea that you haven't, you believe you've already said
that you're aware of her recording a bunch of videos. Oh, is
this logs of Destiny admitting that he got videos from her already?
What is this? Uh, the way that she would record video content
is her boyfriend would record her on Discord while she guys and
she would send me the videos at sometimes after. And her boyfriend
equals that guy. I recognize my own logs when I see them. When
did I leave? When did I put these out? I recognize that he told
me this. He did tell me this. Yeah. So, like this is what we're
talking about the whole time. Like the videos she recorded with
other guys. Like he's just like it's just lie after lie after
lie after lie. Send this to Willie Mac. Dude, it's all out there.
It's like it's crazy to me that
he just is comfortable like lying the whole time. Was it on or
off the record? We didn't say it was off the record. I believe
that means on the record. I just I don't get it, man. That's
all that's all I can say about this. It has nothing to do with
videos or pictures, anything else. It has to do with when you
are um that if if you understand what I'm saying, you understand
what I'm saying. He's >> Nobody understands what you're
saying. Literally, can anybody give me any reasonable interpretation
of this? I'm backing it up a little bit. I actually have to take
a bit and get some water. I'll be right back. But somebody if
anybody could give me any reasonable interpretation of what he
is saying through this whole analogy whatever this is I have
no idea when I go to build my computer let's say that I'm trying
to think of I can't do this with an analogy this statement is
being interpreted as though I don't know or I have no idea how
I'm supposed to treat stuff that I have archived for a court
case when another reading of the statement is you don't know
what will be relevant related to a court case if that makes sense
that's Well, that's all I can say about this. It has nothing
to do with videos or pictures, anything else. It has to do with
when you are um that if if you understand what I'm saying, you
understand what I'm saying. He's reading this is like, "Oh, I
have no clue what uh what I'm supposed to do or what I what is
the law or what I have no idea about any blah blah blah blah."
But that's that's the he's a layer removed from what this is
relevant to. >> Hiding or destroying evidence. I'm pretty
sure I have an obligation to preserve this stuff. This is not
someone who's confident they're doing the right thing. Destiny
says he could keep it because of his court case with Pixie. >> Now,
he spends time doing nobody. I've never said anything along the
lines of like, "Oh yeah, um, so here is my uh statemandated lawyer
protected collection of samp blah blah blah. This is how it's
being read or whatever." But obviously there my understanding
is there would be no law firm that would ever tell you to do
that ever. Um, nobody would this is not a thing. Okay, that's
this is not a thing going through this rose person who supposedly
dropped
about. Um, I am able to verify the authenticity. Nobody close
able to verify the authenticity. >> Literally anybody can
verify its authenticity right now. Okay, I'm back. Okay, I think
I almost got it. I think I almost got it, guys. I think I've
almost got it. Oh, one second. I think I've almost got it. I
think I know what he's saying. At least for this part. Okay,
let me roll it back. Let me roll it back for you to wherever
those logs are. When he says, "I don't think I'm allowed to delete
it. Lol." I don't even know if it counts as Oh, no. I don't.
Pretty sure I still have an obligation to preserve. I I actually
was going to say if he was saying I don't know if I can delete
it or not, he might be saying like I don't know if it will be
relevant, which I don't even know what that means necessarily.
Like like maybe he like talked about the Pixie video in one of
these videos.
I don't know where he'd be going with this. I thought I almost
had it, but then I go back and look at the logs and it doesn't
make sense. I was like trying to cook in my head what he could
be saying, but I just don't even know remotely what he's talking
about. >> I have an obligation to preserve this stuff.
This is not someone who's confident they're doing the right thing.
Destiny says he could keep it because of his court case with
Pixie. >> Now he spends time. Nobody I've never said anything
along the lines of like, "Oh yeah, um, so here is my uh statemandated
lawyer protected collection of blah blah blah. This is how it's
being read or whatever, but obviously they're
my understanding is there would be no law firm that would ever
tell you to do that ever. Um, nobody would. This is not a thing.
Okay, that's this is not a thing." going through this rose person
who supposedly GB farms has dug up stuff about um I am able to
verify the authenticity. Nobody close to me is able to verify
the >> Literally anybody can verify its authenticity right
now but I've been preached blindly repeat destiny. >> You
can say Destiny's responsible. You can say a lot of things but
first off the person's age hasn't been confirmed. >> False.
Just because you're too lazy to look doesn't mean that. >> This
one parking ticket does indeed exist at this point though with
how crazy thing is. I don't even know if I ever spoke to this
actual person. Okay. I don't even [__] know at this
point. All right. Um because again, all of the information there,
it's not like there's a victim that's come forward or somebody
related to the situation that's come forward. All of the information
has spun off of the tidbits that this guy. Sorry, did I um did
I just mishar? Okay. Is Cyber watching? Is Cyber watching right
now? New defense just dropped. It wasn't her
brother one. Okay, that still doesn't help. It would still be
child that he was retaining, right? He was still made aware that
this person was a minor. So, it still be child, okay? Because
the person is undoubtedly that age. But also, I missed it. Well,
I I crazy thing is I don't even know if I ever spoke to this
actual person. Okay. I don't even [__] know at this
point.
>> Yeah. So, do we not remember that when he was trying
to tell Pixie how much he trusted this person, how much he respected
her privacy, how much he was trying to get her not to sue him,
not to like freak out. I talked to this person multiple times
on the phone. We were really, really close. We were really, really
close. Also, there's one other defense he used. Okay, there's
one other defense he used. It's all in his affidavit. There's
no way he put the phone thing in his affidavit, right? There's
no way he put that in his affidavit cuz there's one other thing
that he's said now, I believe. Did he not say that he checked
her identity that he that via the Twitter DMs that he asked for
ID or something and he thought he saw a college ID? How does
get her college ID and get her writing her name on a paper with
like the date to confirm that she's real? How the did that happen?
And now he's going, "Guys, I don't even know if I really talked
to her." Like, he's run himself he's he's tied himself in so
many knots at this point that I just don't understand where he
could possibly be going. And like I'm sitting here, I'm like,
"Dude, it's uh it seems like he's just totally like uh he's falling
apart." But some other people seem to think like this sounds
compelling. I really don't get it. Was the college ID request
ever verified? No. But it was what he told to I believe Tom Foolery.
I believe he was told this by Tom Foolery or sorry, I believe
Tom Foolery said that Destiny told him this. I'm not getting
this firsthand. This is what I remember from Tom's stream. Yes,
remember he said he did. Yes, I do remember this, Jacob. I do
remember that he said he was doing long voice calls with Rose
when he was trying to get Pixie to not freak out. Yep, I do remember
that. The funny thing is is like I don't even know I don't even
know what the truth is there. Like I it seems like she used to
do Discord calls to like sell people or something, right? Or
Skype calls or some [__] So I don't know. Maybe Destiny
was on those. I don't even know which one's true. This guy's
lied in so many directions. I have no idea what's true. Didn't
earlier he say Willie do Rose. Yes, he tried to say Willie Doc
Rose when he himself had done those things. Obviously. Wouldn't
Destiny have Rose's name and address from the per purchase of
Destiny's t-shirt? You would think so.
lying fatly.
He's doing something fatly. Um because again, all of the information
there, it's not like there's a victim that's come forward or
somebody related to the situation that's come forward. All of
the information has spun off of the tidbits that this guy basically
leaked on Kiwi Farms who is trying to blackmail and extort me.
That's where and then all of the research has just been to try
to destroy my career. That's it. Nobody cares about like a victim
or any other bull here. Like that's where all of the information
is coming from. Not to say that it is necessarily wrong or necessarily
right or whatever. like things can be right or wrong past that,
but it's not it's not there's a lot of weird stuff. Whatever
the whatever by the time this core case ends and then hopefully
more um by the time everything is like settled with this, there
are going to be some collection of facts where some things are
very hard to account for cuz something very weird um happened.
Uh Willie altered the 104 date on the 4th of October earlier
in the vid to remove ambiguity by the way. Yeah, I I don't know.
People are making that assumption, but that assumption might
be true based on how parking tickets are read. I'm not sure.
>> You guys are all admitting that Destiny didn't know
the person's It's not just the parking ticket.
>> There's multiple different databases that say this is
her birthday.
>> It's like not even a little bit. It's not even a little
contestant >> age at the time until years later. And that's
only the alleged age. >> If somebody tells you that you
have nuds of an alleged minor, are you going to keep him? What
kind of commentary is >> Like he keeps like
he this solo guy has every incentive to scare me off of trying
to find him. >> Oh, so this is November 24th. So, this
isn't this is before the videos were leaked, right? Why I say
this? Uh, dude, I'm just glad that more people in the chat are
starting to see it, too. I felt like I've seen this for a while.
Okay, we're all getting through this like stage of just total
disbelief. There's a reason why it took so long for anybody to
have any information about um the alleged victim or whatever
or victim or person or perpetrator or honey potter. I don't even
know what the call at this point, right? And that's because they
worked or at least he worked so hard to scrub every bit of information
from this person off the internet as much as they could. nudes
of an alleged minor. Are you going to keep them? What kind of
commentary is this? This is crazy. >> If you don't see
why him having a court case where this is re and his lawyer tells
him not to delete it, doesn't matter. Like, I don't know. I think
you guys are >> Rose's nudes are not related to his court
case. His court case is about him sharing Pixie's nudes with
Rose. So, you it's it's such an unbelievably >> informed
him that Rose might be a minor
it's just
plugged up right now. Okay. He's like getting off in front of
us from all the humiliation. It's insane. Yeah, it's it's such
an unbelievably >> informed him that Rose might be a minor
two months before any court case started. Grief blindly agreed
that yeah, Destiny's lawyer would have told him to keep C for
his legal case. But what is your source? I didn't seen one lawyer
>> To be clear also, I haven't said I've never said that
statement before.
>> Miss that agrees with that >> person. Which statement?
>> Yeah, Destiny's lawyer would have told him to keep for
his legal case, but what is your source? I seen one lawyer
>> to be clear also. I haven't said I've never said that
statement before.
>> This that agrees with that. >> This person was
factually underage. Therefore, this is factually
that completely changes the dynamic from something the lawyer
might not have to report because he doesn't know one way or another
to something he'd say, well, now we've got to talk about this.
Now, we've got to disclose this to the court. I'm just saying
and presenting out there as always professionally, hey, here's
the the attack, here's the defense, right? And it doesn't look
good for >> So, I so legal mindset and criminal criminally
suspect or whatever these two lawyer guys. So, just to be clear,
I think both of these guys are the ones that said that I had
no representation initially, that this is a slam dunk case for
Pixie, that I was going to be completely I mean, I think they
said you were acting like you didn't have representation, but
I did. Wait, did I think le I think they said that based on the
initial filing that if that were true, if the evidence were true,
and I think there hasn't been evidence of some of the things
in the initial filing.
Love when the title said lawyers, it's over. buried that I had
no idea what was going on. Just to be clear, that was these two
guys cuz I think the crimally suspect guy shows up later. But,
you >> this does not look good. This is in addition to
a civil case. So, this is gone for something that is pure >> um
sweatback. I know um this will come back at some point. I'm confident.
I very much like Cherry being on stream, too. I think it's Listen,
uh there's there's not not me. There's another streamer who said,
you know, streaming right now, it's like uh GTA on five stars
right now. Okay. A little crazy. There's helicopters in the air.
All right. I'm good to come out and do streams on whatever, but
like we're going to chill for a little bit. All right. We're
just chilling. All right.
But I understand. Yeah, I agree with >> Purely civil to
something that is now potentially criminal. >> Paul Beaser
says 17. That's illegal. But hardly, it's child. You cannot have
pictures of minors. It doesn't matter if the age of consent is
16. Like here in Ohio, you could a 16-year-old. You can't have
naked pictures of them if they're under 18. No. You're done.
He says, "I don't think I'm allowed to delete I don't know if
it counts as hiding or destroying evidence. So, here's the deal.
Notice what Destiny isn't telling you. My attorney told me to
do this because I guarantee you he hasn't told his attorney,
"Hey, I've got Also, guys, we got an hour left on the stream.
We are nine eight subs away from another hour on the stream."
Okay, 8 hours away. If you guys like the content, you want more
time on the stream, you want more analysis, you want more of
all of this, all right, go ahead, donate. Appreciate all of the
all the support you guys give, okay? Appreciate it all. Don't
forget about the Patreon. patreon.com/jok.
I'm not going to chill that long. Um, if we don't go long tonight,
honestly, it was mostly just a chill night. I'm kind of fine
with taking a night short and getting some other stuff on the
back burner going. Okay. Need to talk to some people. Need to
get some stuff in motion. So, if we if we end up going short
tonight, that's okay. Child kicking around on my computer. What
do I do about that? There's a discovery demand and he has to
turn that over. Pixie can't hold it. Like I said, Pixie her attorneys.
No, you like childies like Chernobyl graphite, you guys. You
can't touch it. How does discovery happen? Well, it'll happen
with what Pixie and Destiny have done or other things Destiny
has done. But the child that doesn't need to be in there. You
can do everything else. Did Destiny send Pixie's pictures out
without permission? That's all we're really worried about right
now. So, what research? What lawyers did Abin Preach go to before
spouting off all of this? They cited nothing and then just declare
that I'm in the wrong. The video ends in such a bizarre way.
>> You can say he's irresponsible. You can say that's stupid.
You can say maybe he should turn it in, but to make that video
and make it seem like something it's not. >> What do you
mean by maybe he should turn it in? Bro, it's Cam. He has to
turn it in. What a shocking video. I'm a claims Destiny already
reported this to >> What do we the And like I said, hey,
listen. People just >> Destiny going to I I hope Destiny
gets that last piece there. I was says Destiny already presented
this to authorities. What are the What are the authorities that
he gave this to? I'm calling FIM me forever. Okay. So, listen.
If I'm going to get locked up, all right, in actuality, I didn't
want to say this. Um cuz I don't want to give ammunition to my
opponents. Okay. But the reason why I've been late every day
is because Oh, another meme. We're just going to meme through
it. We're just going to meme through it. The FBI comes to my
house every day and they sees all of my devices and I have to
run down to Best Man. I have to reby everything and reset up
my studio every single time. So, this is like my 47th computer
set that they uh haven't seized from me yet. Uh hope >> uh
do you have kick data for recurring/returning viewers? Feels
like it has to be really high. Uh yeah, the retention on the
stream's pretty good obviously. Like really really good. We have
really high retention on the stream. Uh lots of the same names.
Not a ton of stuff. Um, we've been lucky in that I've been like,
as I get more active on Twitter, it seems like being more active
on Twitter seems to translate to more people following the Twitter
links through, join the stream. So, that's probably going to
have to be a part of the strategy is getting more active on Twitter.
Everybody has subs. Yeah, cuz that's we use, you know, kick subs
as the primary monetization method anyway. So, so yeah, true.
>> Hopefully I don't come back tomorrow >> We keep
going. Um, this is a claim that I'm seeing repeated by so many
people,
uh, including lawyers. Uh, this idea that I I just I'm not going
to dive into this too much, but I after my court case, I can
say this work. >> This is probably I mean, I can't see
us continuing after today unless he does something. Um, I just
don't know how he tops himself at this point, right? You know,
I could speculate, but I don't know how he tops like the the
things he's been doing recently
in any way. How do you top proving that the girl you is a minor?
Like, so you're so spiteful to KF, okay, that you prove that
the girl you is a minor? I just don't know. I don't know how
you get past that. Like, we've reached like peak load. I don't
think there's anywhere you can go from here. I think like you've
already I think you've already
hit the the end.
Right. Like I don't know. Yeah. I I I actually don't know. So,
we'll see. We'll see what what happens. If there's like movement
in the Pixie case, maybe I'll cover the Pixie Docs, but it seems
like we're probably going to slow down again. We'll go back to
standard drama stuff. Honestly, if there was good drama stuff
today or if there was good chorus content that I was aware of.
I haven't seen anything happen there. There's a panel tomorrow.
There'll be panels throughout the week. There's more chorus stuff.
I'd switch over to that. But I just haven't I haven't been there
for like a lot of the
Yeah. I basically if there's like other good content tonight,
I would have done that. That's why I did a bunch of other stuff
as well. Oh, Peter Prosperity, thank you for the three months.
Let's go. You're tripping about course. No, I'm not. Loki Coco,
what do you think I'm wrong on on Chorus? I'll just show you
what What am I wrong about on Chorus? The only thing you could
think I'm The only way you could think I'm wrong is if you don't
know what my position is, cuz I'm just correct.
Talked about living learn. Maybe we'll check that out after.
You understand that Loki Coco is an actual person, right? Well,
using this chat, so it's always a decent chance. I'm waiting
for Loki Coco to respond. We're waiting. We're waiting. Was Libman
learn mostly a circle joke? We'll see. I noticed Josiah wasn't
there at all. The editorialization hammed it up and it is more
akin to a fellowship.
Uh, you just totally out entirely. I feel like I should time
you out for like an hour for being such a Loki Coco. I asked
you where you thought I was wrong. Those are opinions I have.
You just gave me opinions that I have. You said I was wrong and
then you just gave me opinions that I have. I'm just going to
leave you. You you operate in shame for the rest of the show.
>> This idea that if you have potentially bad material
that >> you changed something from yesterday. I said the
editorialization was was uh like aggressive. I said it was bad.
I said the the title of the by line they gave the wrong impression.
Said the factual importing reporting was entirely correct. Yeah.
you should run to the police and turn everything into them is
it is a thing where if somebody says that you can im >> I
asked him where I was wrong he gave me a positions I agree with
doesn't know what my positions are >> immediately disqualify
every single thing this >> oh hold on I'm cutting this
[__] >> you should run to the police and turn
everything into them is it is a thing where if somebody says
that you can immediately disqualify every single thing this person
has to say about anything related to criminal law or anything
doing to do with law lawyering or criminal anything. It is probably
the single most
statement I have ever heard in my entire life. Um I've seen a
lot of people run it's actually so guys if you think you have
child you think you first thing you should do is go to the cops
with it. You're such a I don't even care to speak to you. Okay.
I don't even care to speak to you. You think the first thing
you should do when you find out you have child is go to the cops.
You're an idiot. You're an idiot. Uh okay. I guess it's going
to be some like kind of shut the [__] up Friday thing.
You maybe argue you should delete it. I just don't know how you
could argue you don't go to the cops and you retain it. That
seems >> What are you talking about? There's an ongoing
legal matter. He submitted this evidence to authorities. >> No,
he didn't. Destiny said he was going to on behalf of Pixie and
then stopped. >> I never said I was doing it on behalf
of Pixie. Pixie was never part of the first legal case that I
was pursuing because she was too busy trying to milk me for money.
Moo. >> Decide to sue. >> Are you going to report
it to the FBI? Uh, maybe the [__] Hold on. Do I have
my Do I have my animation? I have like a I have like a Destiny
LCO animation that's kind of like the Kelly Gene one.
but it's not quite finished. So I I thought about using it. We'll
see. >> The when I was doing work with the New York law
firm, the goal was initially cuz the packet that we put together
was um a thing that we were I think I don't remember. The original
packet was going to DOJ. That was the goal of that originally
because I thought that the the stuff that the solo guy even if
the girl is underage was um criminal in behavior one trillion
to the DOJ and >> as far as I know he never followed through
with this. Everyone including professionals is saying there's
no shot he pulled his lawyer that this was cease. So to me it
clearly seems like he's lying if you
like I'm trying to imagine. No I actually I know I know the I
know why I oh it's it could actually it all tracks. >> Is
there a statement that we're going to get at some point or >> Okay.
So, people think that I'm like the most arrogant person in the
universe just because I happen to be debating a bunch of people
that generally are [__] Okay, which I'm sorry. I
can't help that. All right, but how does this flailing look any
good? Um, there are people that as long as he signals correctly.
So, I've talked about how Andrew Wilson's really really good
at this, right? Andrew Wilson's really incredible at even when
he's dead wrong on something, he will signal like strength. He
will signal confidence. It does not matter how incorrect he is,
he will act like he's the most incorrect person in the world.
And as long as Destiny signals confidence, everybody who's left
in DG at this point will totally believe him, right?
So he signals confidence despite like clearly being shook. He
like signals he's like, "Ah, I don't even know how these people
could like possibly
No, I do get it. I actually do get it, guys. I do get it, actually."
Right. So he does this. He does this whole performance and everybody
in DG will just believe him on that. They'll just believe him.
It's like, "Oh, you're totally correct on this." Uh, hold on.
Let me see. One second. But I tend to know what I know and I
tend to know what I don't know. Um the initial claim was that
I was going to represent myself because I'm so smart. I know
more than every single lawyer. Um and I'm going to represent
myself and that's why it's going to be a [__] disaster.
Uh because apparent I never said that. Uh nobody intelligent
said that that you were going to represent yourself. I think
I think some people me'd because you're an arrogant like douchebag,
but I don't think people took it seriously. Like you have a lot
of money. No lawyer understands how filing dates work or deadlines
and think that if you don't file something immediately that means
that you are litigant pro or whatever. So then the second thing
was that I I guess because I know so much or whatever I would
just lie and hide things from my lawyers. They're your lawyers.
Why would I hide something from my why would I hide something
from my legal team? Why would I myself? Why would I pay so much
money and then myself that hard and be like oh hey guys uh whoops
lol. Like the only person that you hurt there is yourself. This
is like hiding from your doctor. Don't hide medical information
from your doctor. Don't hide anything relevant to a legal case
from your legal team. How stupid would that be? But if you want
to make that assumption, okay, want to interpret my messages
in the worst way possible. >> So what my hypothesis is
is if you if you put everything together here, I think Destiny
like subtly signaled through a hypothetical with Andrew like
if this were to be somehow, how would that affect the court case?
And they, you know, through not a whole lot of obiscation
ca sort of came to this understanding that if we have to report
it, that could be a negative inference against us. Like if we
have to report it and turn it over and delete it, that would
be a negative inference. Actually could topple this whole case
against you, right? Cuz if you sent a video or you received the
video like after this date and it has to be deleted, that could
topple the whole case against us with a negative inference, right?
So that would be bad.
Um, and so I don't want you to delete anything and you just maintain
that you did not know that she was under 18, right? You just
keep maintaining that. As long as you maintain that, we'll have
plausible deniability. If it comes out that she is under 18,
then you can like go to the cops or something. That's probably
what I would guess happened. Uh, that's just my best guess. That's
based on no facts other than, you know, sort of information I've
I've received or that we've covered on stream. So that to me
seems like the most likely thing is I'm aware that this person
could be under 18 and he would have Andrew would have said like
hypothetically in that situation. They should probably like not
say anything, maintain the you know the plausible deniability
that they think they're 18 or over and just in unless it's proven.
You could just keep holding on to that and we just pretend that
we think she's above 18 and and that's the whole So he should
have gone to the cops in the last week. Yes. He I think he has
no way to avoid going to the cops now. The whole thing is fainting
complete ignorance over her age. She still does it even when
the evidence is in his face. Again, I think he has to do this
because I think if he admits that it's proven anywhere, they
have to delete that evidence, there's a negative inference penalty
possibly in the case. And suddenly they could when when that's
deleted, the jury can go or or something along those lines. Let's
say Destiny sent something back to them, right? Suddenly the
jury is told and could be instructed. Actually, if you um if
his lawyers dude, Legitious Gamer, did they really write in Destiny's
affidavit that they exchange? There's no way. Hold on. Hold on.
I have to go find this real quick. Court listener. Court listener.
There's no way. Affidavit of Steven K. Banell Jr. What is this?
So, in early 22, I was contacted by on Discord by an individual
who used the screen name Rose. Rose and I maintained an online
friendship through 2023. During our friendship, we shared explicit
messages and content with each other, including the video that
plaintiff and I made together. I never identified plaintiff by
her legal name, her screen name, or otherwise in my communications
with Rose. Likewise, Rose never identified plaintiff by name
or otherwise. Yeah, that's not great. That's not great.
Uh and content with each other.
Oh boy.
I've been watching a lot of Kino Casino. Whoa, buddy. Okay, I
I should get it better. I should record myself and be able to
do that off the top of my head. Okay, bro. Read number nine.
Based on information believe I have not sent the video to anyone
other than Rose. I certainly have not sent the video to anyone
since I sent the video to Rose on April 9th, 2022. Attached here
too as exhibit C is a true and correct copy of my Discord exchange
with Rose dated April 9th, 2022 beginning at 8:06 p.m. So this
is the one of him sending the video Pixie. Time stamps on page
two. So this is just confirming that it was before the date.
So they confirmed that it was sent before the date. Okay. All
right.
Alert. I can go get a triangle. All right. Ding ding ding ding
ding ding
I can't even believe this guy. I I could totally do a PPP impression.
I could totally do it. I should figure it out. I watch them enough
at this point. I don't watch them a ton. It's just like usually
I'm looking for content in the morning and I'll be looking uh
I'll be looking for something on YouTube and sometimes there's
just clip channels, right? Seen a soundboard clip? No. You need
to make up an accent? I probably don't. Anyway, that's that's
uh not great. Okay. To sign an affidavit saying
I did share explicit messages and content with with this girl.
Yeah, she did. She did share it back with me. Yes. Yes. She just
confirmed he wasn't forthcoming with his lawyers. If he was,
there's no way they would have included that. So again, he might
have been forthcoming in that let's say he said to his lawyers
like hypothetically I was told this, okay, that she might be
a minor. Although, yeah, I don't know cuz then the logs could
easily be introduced as evidence and a man. Yeah, I don't >> Oh,
and you want to be the basis for some FBI? I know Destiny um
I a little early on this. He stringed it in and he saying, "Oh,
really Mac mre what I was saying." I'm like, "There's there's
no miscalculation there." And like if you were that incorrect
in your words and you're not that stupid, Destiny's pretty eloquent
when he needs to be. Yeah. You know, how do you eloquent when
he needs to be? Yeah. When I'm making public statements or when
I'm writing formal statements or when I'm writing manifestos.
Yeah. Not when I'm just DMs with somebody and putting omega ls.
Like, yeah, by the way, I've got hundreds of gigabytes of child
omega lol. Like, do you want some lol? Like, who why would I
You accidentally say, you know, I got more cheese pizza than
Papa John. I I don't know that I've heard very many like legitimate
arguments.
I think I've just heard like the spuring
the memes
just spuring memes and like basically no arguments.
Like not a single coherent argument in return to any of this
video. It's just him leaning into memes being like, "Oh yeah,
I did we did vaginal analysis of this girl or spuring." It's
crazy. Sean's chat is funny dunking on Destiny. I mean like I
was starting to have a bit of a panic attack. Like he's laying
out I've got it and this idea that I have to save >> So
I said if Destiny wants to prove people wrong, he should get
a public statement of his lawyer explaining this. >> This
is another thing that is
that is the most thing why the
why?
This isn't even a thing that would ever Why? Hey legal team,
can you guys go make a public statement because a bunch of YouTubers
are saying why the why what? Uh so he's explained this multiple
times. I can tell you exactly why this would be a good idea.
Okay, it's for the exact reason he said his number one concern.
It's for his exact number one concern, okay, when he started
this video. PR
PR and him saying repeatedly that his public reputation is the
most important thing to him and people think he's a is the worst
most not think he's a is the most important thing to him. He
has repeatedly
repeatedly said that that's the most important thing that he
cares about his public reputation the most. Okay. And he will
not exonerate himself here in any way. This is the first time
he's been able to exonerate himself on something completely.
And he has failed to do so. Every other time he's revealed any
amount of content he needs to to show that he is not in the wrong
in a public way. Whenever he has some silver bullet evidence
that he could, which is not often, by the way, he's not stressed.
I am not commenting, okay? But it's he he goes why why would
I ever do this?
uh for the exact reason you've been commenting on the legal case
the whole time. For the exact reason you've been doing content
on your legal case, you care way more about the PR from this
than the actual outcome. Or I mean the other thing he could do
is he could just explain to me how in the world the like him
exonerating himself here. How does he even affect the outcome
of his uh of his pixie case? I don't even I don't even get it.
He would have to explain like there's some way he could affect
the outcome of his pixie case by exonerating himself of like
u courting child here. How? But he's he's basically saying that
even if I explain if I explain the mechanism by which I'm being
I will also be that's what he said >> is not currently
in a court case over Ros's material it would be such an easy
way to clear things up but no he writes it off as an impossibility
>> and I should probably get on from his legal counsel
however having allegorories okay innocence illegal I don't see
one lawyer do this for I don't know how you have to be to think
that one that any lawyer would ever agree to do this >> companies
have lawyers write up statements for them all the time and if
you went to the police he should show a report if you have to
be to think that one that any lawyer would ever do this >> companies
have lawyers write up statements for them all the time and if
>> companies have lawyers Lawyers write out statements
for them all the time. Statements about ongoing court cases.
What are you talking about? He's talking about like PR firms.
Usually, by the way, when you have a PR firm write a statement
for you, it's I didn't do this. These allegations are entirely
false, right? I don't know if you notice this. For basically
all of these things, he doesn't say that, right? He doesn't say
like all of the things they've charged, all the things they said.
He doesn't say, "Oh, all of these things are false." Right? He's
not even denied most of he he for a long time wasn't denying
any of the allegations at all. He had to come up with like his
implicit consent argument. He needs to see the evidence against
him, right? But all he would have to do is have his lawyer say
um what would it be? Our our client kept us like uh made it clear
that they were informed by an unreliable party that this might
be and we advised him to keep it and not pursue this further
or or advised him to keep it and gave him like this this you
know because this the question of the is actually as far as I
could tell totally irrelevant to the
The only thing a lawyer will ever say generally is oh my client
is innocent of all charges or my client we're going to we are
confident that we're going to succeed in court. What are you
talking >> He went to the police. He should show a report.
If he just does either of >> He quickly cut that. Did he
quickly cut that off? Was I imagining that? Hold on. >> See
in court. What are you talking about? My client is innocent of
all charges or my client we're going to we are confident that
we're going to succeed in court.
I thought maybe he might have cut that. My client is innocent
of all charges. He doesn't like that argument. >> Talking
about he went to the police. He should show a report. If he just
does either of these things, he's in the clear. So why doesn't
he just do them? He skipped the entire point of H3's video. I
almost feel like it's all fake and he is punking everyone for
lols. Okay, I think we all have to admit Moody Morgan that while
this is like an entertaining possibility. Okay,
this would be even this would be topping the previous attempts
at loadoutm by like what are you I tricked everybody into thinking
I was a Is that Destiny's like cuda gr that's his uh peace day
resistance to his career? I convinced everyone I was a Huh? Is
that Is that really That's the the the cake topper for the massive
dessert that's been his entire career. Okay. Is I convinced everyone
as a Why did you do this? You were like starting a a whole group
with like the DNC. You're trying to You're trying to be like
a DNC person in charge of campaigns and stuff. Why would you
try to convince everybody you're a pet? I convince everybody
I'm a I don't I don't get it. I don't understand. I don't see
where it's coming from.
Seems very goofy to me. Yeah, it would be something like this.
Hey guys, look at how much of af I can be off as jokes on them.
I was only pretending to be afest to get their attention. Like
he's actually crushing.
No, no, Moody Morgan. I actually think it would be worse because
the thing isn't actually real here. I've said this, right? He's
not like trying to like a 10-year-old. That's I don't think that's
something Destiny's ever been afflicted with, right? It's like
the colloquial internet version where he's having inappropriate
relationships with people who are of questionable age. Okay.
And and I think it's more mentally ill to like try to convince
people that you did a 17-year-old than it is to just like tell
the truth if if that wasn't the truth. That was that's far more
that's way further down the road to like some major serious like
pathology. Okay. It's it's it's
like crazy at that point. >> Yeah. The majority of that
he died. He won't even provide the quote unquote good faith interpretations
of the messages he sent. I've seen >> just to be clear
cuz I I don't think like uh when we call him a it's like he's
holding child right
when he's in the right he usually directly conf cuz I I dude
whatever it's all good give me 6 months or a year whenever the
court case is over.
Guys, give me 6 months or a year. 6 months or a year. 6 months
or a year. He's so just No, I don't know why he played this video.
There's actually not a single counterargument laid out here.
Except there's one thing he played this video for. Okay, just
one. That was to tell DJers, okay? Go after Willie Mack for doxing
Rose. Willie Mack just docked Rose. He's a sick mother. You got
to go after this guy. That's like the only thing that he did
that that's the only argument he made in this entire video. And
we've obviously proven how insanely disingenuous it is.
>> Brains receded here. He's just constantly deflect. He's
like, "Look at all these jokes Ethan made in the past from the
channel >> because he opened his video with 15 minutes
of [__] jokes that I've made." Yeah. No [__]
It was horrible [__] We went to this channel. This
was like 8 years old. He was in this chat
on screen. I can't even believe it. I haven't gotten into Ethan's
jokes yet, but I do think it's kind of funny that I feel like
I've heard him say similar >> It's called Children's Joy
TV for a reason. The guy knows how to give pleasure children.
Children's Joy TV. Baby gets raped by a syringe and gets injected
with AIDS virus. When we see something like this, are we supposed
to call the police? >> Am I on I feel like I'm definitely
on the FBI watch list now. >> I don't know how many FBI
watch list jokes. Maybe he is, maybe he isn't, but again, if
like that's the standard, then >> Bro, you watch a real
video on an 8-year-old shaking his These are not the same. Also,
>> a video. Oh my god. What?
That's uh I don't even understand the soying here. Is he like
going to say that it's not a live stream?
Actually, it wasn't a video. Actually, it was a live stream.
It was a live stream of me watching that 8-year-old shake his
It was not a video. I did not have it on my hard drive. It was
a live stream of that 8-year-old shaking his There's no way.
But uh I do think this is just a cheap shot from Willie, but
like obviously Willy's going to throw a couple cheap shots, right?
Sometimes that'll happen. There'll be a cheap shot or two. Okay.
Yes, true. In my more prolific internet days when I would download
the 8-year-old helicopter. True. Thank you, Willie. True. Apparently,
that's that that defense lands. We got a lot of Omega lols in
the chat. It was live.
Yeah, Willy's Willy's the guy who's a here.
Willy Willy's definitely the guy who's making an ass of himself
in all this, guys. Willy's really just kind of Willy's just kind
of threw his credibility by the wayside by pointing out that
Destiny clearly had child >> would look at some of Ethan's
old edgy jokes a bit differently if he admit to having to another
content creator, but he didn't. You did. And now people are raising
eyebrows. Ethan points out Destiny defending boss for getting
off to Lolly feels creepier now. >> Who cares about Lolly?
Who cares about drawn? Imagine your life is so boring. Do you
anime? >> Wait, someone actually said that? Yes, they they
do actually. They do actually say that. They do actually say
things like this. Yes. >> In cartoon girls. Imagine your
life so boring that you care about children. Imagine being so
bored in your life that you actually care if grown-ups want >> Destiny
doesn't really engage. >> Yeah, Benny. I understand. Okay.
Yes, I understand that this is actually how it is. Benny, I'm
just saying Willie was just getting a cheap shot in. Right. He's
like he's doing a little like, oh, I like Ethan Destiny. That's
all he was doing there. That's not a real That's not a real claim.
And a lot the way a lot of the other things in here are. He doesn't
defend his position. Instead, he goes for laughing at Rick and
Morty. >> Engage or defend my position? Cuz this wasn't
the time to have a debate on lollipop. What? What was that? Photoshopped.
Wait, was what >> I'm going to give you that animated cartoon
girls. >> Imagine your life so boring that you care about
children. Imagine being so bored in your life that you actually
care if grown-ups want minors. >> Destiny doesn't really
engage. He doesn't defend his position. Instead, he goes after
Ethan for laughing at Rick and Morty. >> Oh, my forehead.
>> Uh, yeah, frugals. I I understand. I think like this
is this is one of those things where that's probably true, right?
It's probably true that there was like some kind of long-term
thing going on there where it was like multiple times they gone
to this live stream and I do agree with that. I don't know that
you could prove anything there. So, >> I wish they just
let go
>> talking about his hairline or something. Guys, my my
hairline's totally fine, guys. My hairline's totally fine. They
lied. They lied about the hairline,
>> Me runs train on >> now. Probably not. But like
is this is this if this is the standard we're going to use? I
mean Jesus Christ. >> Obviously laughing at the absurdity
of degenerate stuff is not the same as getting off to it. But
Destiny's not here to make sense. He's here to go. >> Laughing
at the absurdity of degenerate stuff is not the same as getting
off to it. What was the context for the 8-year-old? That was
I guess that was me downloading a video of it. So it was getting
off to it. I guess that feel when I 10% of the time I just need
the >> orange. He plays a bunch of clips of them making
fun of cringing creepy videos online. Leaves out all the context.
Both of these guys >> leaves out all the context. What?
What? Definitely make her share of inappropriate jokes, but what
Destiny is just different. His are coming from leak group chats.
>> He then shared this lude image of a child with his friends
and said that he's going to get arrested someday. >> Imagine
receiving a bikini pic from a 15-year-old in your DMs, a fan
of yours, and being like, "She's so hot. I need to share this
with the boys." >> His friend asks, "Picks, please." Destiny
sends what was a public Instagram photo in a bikini and goes,
"Girl on the left so hard." I >> think it was Facebook,
not Instagram. I don't know if Instagram even existed >> To
say no, I'm going to get arrested in one of these MLGs, man.
His friend replies, "Who cares? It's not like you're 40." Destiny
tries to recontextualize this. Him warning his friends to watch
out for jailb. >> That was literally what the conversation
was about.
It was not. And it doesn't matter how hard you pause to spur
and scream about it. It's very obvious what the messages are.
Uh Willie just proves this out entirely.
Like he's just it's just a lie that he keeps trying to do. He's
probably going to keep trying to do. Uh I don't know. Maybe he
didn't pre-watch this enough. He just doesn't realize what's
going to come next. Be careful. Does it not say that? Are there
is there more to this conversation? I think this is published
somewhere. Public Instagram photo. Who cares? It's out for
Wait, what? There's a public somewhere. >> Faith likes
pre-teen. Pics, please. Faith likes pretines. But what happened
then? Girl on the left. >> Public Instagram photo. Who
cares? It's Watch out for jail. >> Yeah, I messaged my
little team or whatever. Obviously, those DMs were pretty crass.
But I mean, the whole point is like, hey, like there people that
DM you pictures. They look older than they actually are. Don't
minor. You're the full convo league. Yeah, I feel like it's somewhere
on a pace. He will show it. Don't do it. >> But these logs
are public. You can see that just being. There's no speech about
people. Don't do it. >> But these logs are public. I've
if you notice, okay, when Destiny actually goes and covers a
drama, when he actually wants to make points, he will pause.
He'll read the whole thing and he'll explain his point right
here. I don't think he pauses to read a single log the entire
time. >> You can see he pauses there. Okay. Is he going
to read this and just tell her to not look at you? You get uncomfortable
when people make eye contact or something. Dude, she's 15. What
the [__] But she sent me pictures. What the [__]
She's huge. that made it so hard to say no. She sent me pictures
that made it so hard to say no. Oh, >> there's no speech
about being >> Oh, he doesn't. He pauses. He reads to himself
a little bit. Who cares? It's not like you're 40 years old. Responds
to fame this hard, but dude, 15-year-old girls, I don't know,
two years and a half ago. I hooked up with a 17-year-old and
they're usually so inexperienced that it's not really worth it.
Raffle,
you want her to do somersaults for you? What the [__]
I know how to do at least a proper hand job. At least do a proper
hand job. Again, hand jobs. The Ain't nobody like a hand job,
bro. What are we doing here? Problem is, after you bang more
than like three chicks, banging hot chicks who suck in bed is
no fun anymore, I think. Okay. How long have you been dating
your current girlfriend, Faith? I dumped her twice over the spans
of seven years and a half. Yeah, dude. Once you've been with
a girl who's likes who likes more than one to two years, randoms
is impossible because they learn you and get so good in that
time span. Is this a warning that like guys, monogamy is the
way? That would have been a more believable story based on the
logs. Guys, I did say the 15-year-old was hard to resist, but
I did reiterate that monogamy is the only way, okay? You need
long-term partners who can learn you >> careful for jail.
It's about them. >> There's no speech about being careful.
Your life is going to be over. Don't do >> But these logs
are public. You can see that they were just doing there's no
>> Wait, did he read that himself? >> There's no
speech about being careful. Your life's going to be over. Don't
do >> But these logs are public. You can see that they
were >> He just doesn't believe it. He doesn't He's like,
"Dude, I could have sworn I I could have sworn I totally said,
"Don't do Don't do this, guys." >> Justin, there's no speech
about being >> This is insane. He is outright lying. And
the crazy part is that we all know it because the video is there
with Destiny replying to H3. Huh? >> This random sex care.
It's about them banging porn stars and stuff. For real, Destiny
has confirmed it. >> Is there not Was it more of that?
Is there not more of this log publicly somewhere? Am I crazy?
I don't want to give a whole lot of credence to this because
Destiny did not hook up with a 15-year-old. As >> Guys,
is there guys, I could have sworn there was something I could
twist here so it didn't look like I was just saying I want to
[__] that 15year-old.
Like, by the way, if there was one message that was like after
all that was like, "Also, guys, I'm just letting you know, watch
out for these hot 15-year-olds at MLG events, that literally
wouldn't make it better now." Like it's clear what the context
of the conversation is. One throwaway line at the end. Would
that really change anything? As one of his friends said, it's
not worth it. I do raise my eyebrows though that one of the reasons
to not do it is because they're inexperienced in bed. Destiny
saying this is a group chat conversation to warn people about
the dangers of jailbait. It's just a lie. They're just exchanging
sex stories. You can be as good faith or bad fate as you want
with this stuff. At one point, Ethan plays a clip of Destiny
saying that 19-year-olds might as well be children to him. And
I think Ethan completely misunderstands this cl. Destiny saying
people should >> No response to any of that. That entire
section plays. There's not a single tangible response except
I didn't think I like rate myself this badly. Only comment in
that entire section. I didn't think I'd rate myself this badly
with these messages.
I hook up with 19-year-olds because they are basically still
children to a 19-year-old might as well be a 15-y old to me.
It's all the only This is exactly what we're saying. 15 13 14
15 also also is >> if you listen to the actual debate here,
I'm arguing with a dude who was literally trying to abduct a
mentally [__] 19-year-old and take her to another
state and pregnant her basically every other time I'm speaking
about this person and their age. I do heard the fact a whole
bunch of others too. >> Yes, Destiny did have this debate.
But at this point in the stream, Destiny was just generally speaking
to his audience. He even goes on to say that his 20-year-old
viewers don't realize how young they are. >> Now, I know
if you're 20 years old, it might bother you to hear that like,
"No, I'm 19. I'm a real adult." Okay, I'm a real adult. Okay,
if your mom and dad, if you live with your mom and dad, your
mom and dad still pay all of your bills. >> Unless he's
referring, unless he thinks every single member of his audience
under the age of 20 is as JF's wife,
then this doesn't make any s this would make any sense that he's
thinking about >> You've never even had a job before. You've
never lived on your own. You're a child. You're very much a child.
You don't know what it's like to wake up and go into work to
work a job you hate because you have to pay a bill. Okay? You
don't know what it's like to have to make a decision between
getting kind of a cool car and a piece of car because you can't
afford it. You don't know what it's like to get called in to
have to work an extra [__] just because you're right.
You don't have any life experience. You don't know anything about
anything. You're a child. So all the people in China like no
19 years old that's an adult. That's an adult dog. No comes up
that you suck when he's 33. It's like what the hell, bro? Even
when Destiny thought she was 19 fit all of this criteria. >> Is
there a response? Do we have a response? We have a single response.
You know what? Base Destiny. Okay. >> All he does is deflect.
What about Solo? What about Ethan's mean Reddit account? What
about Ethan's dad? Ding his mom at 21 when she was only 16. Really?
You're going to bring family into this when your own kid is saying
crazy stuff about you on the internet? This drama is so scorched
earth. Destiny's audience made this graphic to make one of how
son never engages with criticism. This >> Wait, how does
my kid even relate to >> I I think he's just saying that
obviously if we're going to bring family members into it, he
could do the same or Ethan could do the same, but they don't
want to do that. I assume. Yeah, he's he's looking for anything
he could tangibly click on to, right? So, he's not I'm still
keeping track. Other than trying to say Willie is a doctor who
doesn't care about Rose's well-being. As funny and hypocritical
as that is, I don't think he's made a single tangible response
to any of the claims made in this video. He's not refuted any
of it. He's just kind of sat back and got completely ripped by
it. Um, which is interesting.
I'm just saying that me saying at 22 that chicks send you pictures
for MLG events that are 15 that are underage that by the way
I explicitly said not not hooking up with. It's not >> Why
doesn't he just quote himself? Cuz he didn't say he didn't say
I'm not these girls. He said, "It's so hard to resist. Her are
so big." Oh, wait. That was one of his other friends said her
so big. But it was, "It's so hard to resist. I'm going to get
I'm going to put in jail at one of these MLGs, man.
He's not saying I'm not going to these girls is really up saying
I have such a hard time." Good. Um,
I just think it's interesting to have the energy that that's
like a pattern of But his dad is like 21, married his mom. She
was 16. He seems to know that. I doesn't feel like he has the
same energy for his dad. That's the reason I'm playing. I don't
know how Nathan ties into this unless he thinks I'm also banging
my kid. I guess 141 19 right >> Fortunately, we don't we
don't talk about hide beyond the fact that some of the details
come from Kiwi Farm when it just doesn't matter. Verified information
is still verified information no matter where it comes >> I'm not
going to sit here and listen to him on all of the on his theory.
>> Alter he lies about the substance of the messages claiming
never admitted to keeping C. >> Does he respond to H here
>> right now? Hide. He hides beyond the fact that some
of the details come from Kiwi Farm when it just doesn't matter.
Verified information is still verified information no matter
where it comes from. I'm not I'm not going to sit here and listen
to him on all of the
>> on his theory alter he lies about the >> so no
response to H >> substance of the messages claiming never
admit to keeping C even though it's in text straw man make fun
of me for documenting talking to the police >> no response
to a only response is his stupid video call the police so it's
on s
what what is his interpretation make fun of me for documenting
me talking to the police first of all you don't need to document
it they document it it's called a police report number one number
two I'm making fun of you for posting a video on it which is
hilarious and
>> Documenting talking to the police trying to act like
Ethan's a hypocrite for making any jokes when the situation is
not the same and it certainly doesn't alleviate him from what
he's done wrong. Avoid heing on small details to avoid the actual
allegations like how he doesn't have all 60. >> That's
basically what this entire thing when the concerning part is
that he does have at least some of that cap. >> Like there's
a whole bunch of like weird lies that came out of Willie Mac
video. People were saying that like I have 60 gigabyte folders
like this is not true. It was like an obvious misreading of a
message show. And then finally name call me your way out of the
heck like none of this is a big deal. Destiny knew that if Rose
turned out to be underage it would be a big deal even saying
if Rose was legitimate minor I'm probably done. I can sweep a
meme for basically anything even though some of it is really
shitty. >> This conversation by the way I know he's living
the rest of us out was logistical and yeah I felt like if when
the all this [__] was leaking back then if that if
that person actually was underage and that solo guy was like
flashing her idea or whatever I'd be like that would be really
bad. That'd be a lot of bad [__] right in a row.
I don't know what this is.
Wasn't Destiny just the pure victim at this point? Like as far
as I knew at this I think as far as most of the internet was
concerned he was like the victim here still like it took until
January for the Pixie stuff to come out. I'm pretty confident
that he was just like a lot of people felt bad for him here.
Well, I guess he was. No, sorry. A lot of people were mocking
him for for being a dick sucker. Uh that is true. That is true.
>> supposed to like prove or whatever. This has nothing
to do with like this is just like yeah, the PR would be a lot
of to deal with the minor. I'm probably done. I can sweep and
meme for basically anything even though some of it is really
he's doing the Donald Trump. I could get away with >> Oh,
it's too bad he it's too bad he read it backwards. Okay, it's
I can sweep a meme my way through basically anything even though
some of it is really this referring to obviously him leaking.
I don't know. I didn't connect this. I guess the the pixie molina
stuff was what I knew at the time was probably not consensual,
right? But if she was legit a minor, but if she was legit minor,
I am probably done. >> Murder. They say I have the most
loyal people. Did you ever see that? Where I should stand in
the middle of Fifth >> Does he I wonder why he doesn't
include that. That >> Why was it exported in reverse order?
Cuz I didn't notice. And then my Discord account got clapped.
Dung devil. So unlucky. Okay. Didn't notice it was exported in
reverse order when I first did it, but
>> by the way, Jessica tweeted that this was uh Willie
Mac's best video. >> And I would lose >> best video
on Destiny. I didn't watch a lot of his other videos, so it felt
weird to say it felt weird to say his best video ever cuz I've
not not seen most of his other videos, right? But I did say best
video on Destiny and it was okay. So I can cut. So I think there's
three ways the situation went down. One is that Destiny really
didn't believe Solo when he said Rose was 17. Pick up the picture
and log just in case he got into legal trouble. Also, Disal did
not believe him either, by the way.
>> I can't help but find like
I I don't want to be like that spiteful, but if Could you imagine
him? Why would you know? Uh I've already explained how like why
I thought this was okay that that this guy was like making it
up and I was pretty sure that the guy was lying.
I thought he was lying, right?
But but if I had a bunch of of the person he was claiming was
a minor, I feel like I would have been in a very concerned position
cuz when I let when I let the what is the solo guy know that
I had found like the Twitter account that was attached to it,
right? He was like, "Oh, you should watch out. There's a lot
of on there." And I was like, "Oh, you're probably just mad cuz
um cuz like her her like pictures are on there or something."
But I still when he told me that, I was like, "Oh, I'm never
going to check any of that [__] ever again. I'm not
risking that." No, thank you. Right.
Destiny apparently felt no no such compulsion. Very interesting.
Rose was doxed confirming she was 17. Destiny was more focused
on how solo would be being the wrong himself. Sharing with me
that he still has the material when I was obviously unhappy with
him asking why he still has CP on his computer. Destiny spoke
on his ass making up that his lawyer told him to keep it and
why he now keeps saying that Rose's age hasn't been confirmed
when he clearly has it. And then when I went public, he panicked
and called me a liar changing his story saying I'm being bad
faith because otherwise he'd be admitting to a felony. This would
be good because that means Destiny isn't a pedophile and he just
mishandled this whole thing. It is a messy situation for sure.
Option two is destiny. >> This would be good because it
means I'm not a pedophile. Is that what is the that's the subject
of the debate right now is whether or not I'm a that's the thing
like what if tomorrow it's revealed that he was 12 and she has
like some accelerated growth he's like oh he's actually he's
a super like Jesus Christ that's okay
I I don't know
I don't I don't know what that's supposed to mean literally zero
tangible responses to anything argued in the
zero zero tangible responses to any of the evidence presented
in the video. Uh the only thing he's had a response for was Willie
Mack seems to not care about Rose cuz he doxed her. Ignoring
the fact that Destiny himself is the one who bragged about leaking
her stuff, he posted pics in chat to bait Kiwi Farms into looking
for her. That's the only thing he's got is guys, Willie must
not care about her at all. He must not care. in the section where
Willie is pointing out that Destiny posted all the information
he's showing on the screen for Kiwi Farms. Not even for a YouTube
video, just for Kiwi Farms. It's
It's like when he said if his tummy was an oven, he would bake
bread or something. If I had an oven in my stomach, I'd use my
tummy to bake bread. I believe is the exact quote. If I had an
oven in my stomach, I could break bread in my tummy. Is actually
the real quote. That's what it is. If I had an oven in my stomach,
I could bake bread in my tummy. Yeah, it's just uh Yeah, it's
just spurging. just lots and lots of spuring. Um and with that,
I don't know that there will be a reason to cover him until something
changes. Uh we'll see right as he like obviously um I'll probably
keep covering if he continues to say like we should like if he
continues to suggest if he continues to suggest sorry that he'll
like dox Doobie or he's going to like menace other people around
communities with with their docs. I'd probably cover like that
stuff because he's a psychopath.
But I don't know. I I can't imagine watching like bor reactions
on the stream. It's just very boring. Um
as much as I like I like doing that just to show that he's lying.
He's just lying the whole time, right? And I do think it's important
to have that like on the record. And I'll be real probably if
if Ri post that to YouTube, it probably does well, right? He's
just updating the DG script. Yeah. I I don't know. It it would
be very interesting to see like how people feel about that. I
guess it's very uncomfortable to watch him. It does make me feel
uncomfortable to watch him. He's very off-putting just when he
does the whole performative outrage thing. He's done this before,
right? Like, oh, if you cared about like he I think he did this
with the Pixie lawsuit, like if you cared about these victims
at all, you would have kept Molina's name out of this when Molina
had made a public statement saying that he didn't have her consent
to share those videos, right? He does this and he was the person
who shared the videos without her consent. And he does the performative
outrage like, "If you cared about her consent or her privacy
at all, you wouldn't bring her name into this." It's like, "Brother,
we know you don't care about this. Why are you making this argument?
It's very weird. Very bizarre."